[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on
sait tous et rejoigne entendu je
rappelle les dates des chronos du 10 au
21 août avec certains membres de
l'équipe voilà qui roule ta fait leur
place bien entendu on va enchaîner par
béatrice et elle fit abattre les deux
copines les deux peuples
[Musique]
allez là ils inventent ils avanceraient
notre chat
à légitimer sexy mittal s'est immiscé
dans sap et valérie voilà ça vous
montrer ce que c'est voilà
allez moi tu vas là
c'est bon mais bon c'est bon c'est bon
ça va mais on a perdu raymond
ça va déchirer merci d'être là merci
c'est n'importe quoi et n'importe quoi
c'est ça qu'on aime et sa croyance
passer n'importe quoi comme ça c'est
tout ce qu'on aime beaucoup mais c'est
vrai c'est ça qu'on aime on ne comprend
pas de cette avenue pour sport d'arista
lors qu'elle put pour quelles raisons
barhoum
finalement et c'est vrai qu'on est
content de faire ce qu'on fait chez tout
le monde voilà on est content empêchés
de pêcher toute la population salut ma
chérie fatah sur match et la natation tu
vas tu vas attention on abuse dans la
gueule ça c'est vrai
alors non mais là c'est l'excès avec
trois trophées chez tout le monde est
content
[Applaudissements]
j'aimerais qu'on ait droit à répond
soyez agrément est reparti
[Musique]
les chéris
j'aimerais qu'ils revoient pense que
nicolas pernikoff
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
d'accord
tadam
voilà empêcher tout le moins dans les
coteaux voilà en fait chier tout le
monde on écoute
d'accord ça
j'aurai un peu plus chaud avoir pigé pas
avant mais les obliger pas d'embellie
[Applaudissements]
m'obligez pas à
jeter dans sa gamme
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ces banlieues sommet daniel est sans
décoller là on a failli y rester un on a
failli perdre daniel halal portugal
partait là elle allait sur footix à dire
est allé s'offrir les chéris l'émission
bat fox soit je vous le dis trois heures
de folie merci d'être avec nous saison
incroyable et on est ensemble jusqu'à 21
heures car bien sûr en direct avec toute
l'équipe merci au voisinage à d'être
aussi sympathique merci les chéris merci
merci beaucoup et danse à l'asmo on va
jouer on va jouer pour pour le faire
gagner un public et on faire gagner de
regarder la bayanne table reconnaissez
leur fameux jeu du portable
le portable qui doit aller le plus loin
possible sur la table sans tomber bien
entendu et on va être là dessus dans un
instant ça va être très très bien ça
bien entendu alors bien naïve adore ce
jeu bien entendu le jeu voilà deux pays
vivent ou est la plus d'ailleurs le jeu
de bénéfices on va arriver les chéris
après bien sûr on va direct en plateau
et là on va faire gagner des cadeaux est
avec nous qui barak s'est pas dit enfin
maintenant il fait un peu le tour est
joué bonjour les cours voilà on fait
chier tout le monde on est content
regardez la maréchaussée ida
les seydoux l'a laissé d'où là ça va mal
se terminer
et seydoux l'a laissé tous là ça va mal
voilà les chéris qu'est ce qu'il fait
mais quoi mais pourquoi mais non mais là
un bel essai mais c'est bon c'est bon
c'est bon c'est bon
c'est bon mais c'est bon c'est bon
d'être là c'est moi vous emmerder paul
maddison la
7 sur le mois qui ne voudrait pas credo
la
voiture c'est vraiment le nécessaire
c'est pas sexy
changement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]